es una de las muchas guerras culturales
de Estados Unidos la de la orientación
sexual y cómo abordarla en el sistema
educativo Florida expandió su ley
conocida como no digas gay los maestros
ahora no podrán enseñar sobre el tema y
sobre identidad de género en ningún
grado escolar las únicas excepciones
serán cuando le exijan los estándares
estatales o como parte de la instrucción
de salud reproductiva además la cámara
prohibió la atención de brindar atención
médica para transiciones de género en
menores el uso del baño que no sea el
del sexo asignado al nacer y la
presencia de niños en espectáculos de
Drag Queens el gobernador ronde santis
dice luchar contra el progresismo y las
diversidades conocidas como woke
esta agenda izquierdista la ideología
Walk es una amenaza Para nuestras
libertades nuestros resultados finales
no nos rendimos a la mafia woke Florida
es donde lo Walk va a morir
la medida que de santis legisla también
llegan protestas en este caso de los
estudiantes de educación superior que
serían los próximos afectados por las
reformas ultraconservadoras los
republicanos quieren eliminar la teoría
crítica de la raza y la teoría queer de
las universidades
estamos muy preocupados con toda la
censura y todo el borrado que están
tratando de hacer con El currículo
creemos que las clases son un espacio
para el pensamiento libre crítico donde
tener conversaciones difíciles
recientemente de santis ha promulgado
una ley que prohíbe el aborto después de
las seis semanas y está en una guerra
abierta con Disney la compañía se opuso
la ley no digas gay y ron de santis
quiere ahora limitar la supervisión de
Disney de sus parques temáticos medidas
con las que busca avalarse entre los
conservadores de Cara a las elecciones
primarias del partido republicano
[Aplausos]